on la connaît c'est comique
la waci comédienne ouais si muriel robin
la vraie date butoir
alors tout le monde en parle l'héroïne
du nouveau film de mehdi charef
s'appelle marie line ce comme ses héros
dans garde à vue comme coluche dans
tchao pantin vous passer avec succès du
comics je tue programmatiquement fin au
sérieux ça a bien démarré
c'est bien oui c'est bien c'est
tellement inquiète la semaine dernière
non vraiment ça drôle de truc que
j'avais cru j'avais pas on entend parler
de ça le mercredi des films ça peu
virtuel
et puis quand ça arrive ça crée trop
d'effets sur les champs-elysées à deux
heures de l'après midi
j'hésitais j'ai tourné côté finalement
je suis allé on me disait les chiffres
ah oui c'est crevant à chaque fois que
vous répondez à une interview que ce
soit dans la presse ou dans là où la
télé ou à la radio
oui toujours c'est ma mère en parlant de
marilyn vous dites pour retrouver cette
dureté j'ai eu qu'à me souvenir
vous racontez votre enfance salif et
quoi faire quand même parce que quand on
sait pas elle gueule pas quand elle a
parlé lui il a parlé musique les
normands je suis désolé raccourci que je
me comprendre mais c'est pas ma main
mais c'est vrai que je connais la dureté
ouais donc je n'ai pas eu à me souvenir
ce que chez avait de la dureté il y
avait de la dureté autour de moi quand
j'étais enfant et j'en ai gardé
alors heureusement c'est parce que je
préfère chez moi donc j'ai pu puiser là
dedans
évidemment là vu le film de merde oui et
alors elle a trouvé ben on se parle peu
à c'est un peu comme dans le film
séverine on se parle pas beaucoup donc
elle a dit qu'est ce qu'elle a dit
elle a dit bien vous avez déclaré s'il
ya vu un papa et une maman classique qui
vous aiment chine avait appelé mon bébé
chéri toute la journée
j'aurais été quelqu'un d'autre oui bah
oui je parle trop près de risque en
disant ça non j'ai pas moi je crois que
voilà les parents c'est extrêmement
important voilà quand on rencontre
quelqu'un il faudra pas lui demander que
tu fais comme métier faut dire qu est-ce
que ta mère donc mer qu'est ce que c'est
dès qu'on prend cinq minutes ça explique
beaucoup de choses
donc si on pouvait s'attaquer au 21ème
siècle ou au mythe de l'amour maternel
ça serait intéressant c'est vrai quand
vous étiez petit quand vous avez couché
chez les copines gt est affreusement
étonné de voir que finalement ils
s'embrassent et le soir en dessous plus
cher mais il se réveiller le matin ils
sont passés à nouveau pour déneigement
avec a gelé ses amis et ça me faisait
ben oui quand on connaît pas ça fait moi
je pensais que c'était c'était partout
comme chez moi quand je disais ils sont
bizarres et je viens pour mes parents
c'est encore plus bizarre qu'est ce
qu'on a c'est en gros c'était d'ailleurs
ce n'est pas en gros c'était marrant ces
gens qui parce qu'on venait lécher la
gueule peut-être d'autres choses à faire
alors quand on connaît pas seysses et
voilà on est étranger
mais c'est parce que vous ai mis tout ça
dans peut-être que le film et bien non
je crois la charge des familles de
quelqu'un d'autre secret sera mis deux
mois à venir quelle autre couleur
naturelle progrès mais c'est plus dur
brune c'est plus dur j'ai vu le jour
dans une émission de chez daniela
lumbroso sur lci
et alors un moment elle était
interloquée parce que vous avez dit et
je crois que c'est un peu le coeur du
film
vous avez dit être tolérant cm1 raciste
pas parce qu'il est raciste et parce que
c'est un être humain et elle n'a pas
compris la lancer la pub et je crois que
non mais non mais je veux dire c'est
vrai la compassion c'est ça quand le
pape va pardonner ali agça qui lui a
tiré des balles dans le ventre c'est
c'est pareil bon c'est vrai que moi je
cherche toujours à comprendre ma tâche
puisque condamné je n'ai pas souvent la
tolérance était à sens unique
et c'est vrai que c'est mieux si marilyn
par exemple dans le film à un moment bon
à la sa carte du front national c'est
parce qu'elle n'avait pas d'autre
solution pour trouver du boulot je
dirais c'est pas parce que les nazis
c'est pas parce qu'elle est raciste et
je sais ce que je trouve bien dans ce
film est tout à fait même le pur et dur
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est savoir
j'aimerais avoir ma soir il dira comment
il en est arrivé là comment est on
arrivé là
il ya des départs on appris dans des
sketches peut passer des heures à se
poser une question à la fin il répond à
cette question et elle achète son
célèbre ou pas ben oui c'est qu'on a une
conviction est serré je crois que tata
ça ça ouais ou pas c'est d'être capable
d'envisager le point de vue de l'autre
ou pas c'est diakhaté ya bull c'était
plus compliqué qu'on en dise il y avait
quelqu'un qui avait très bien on est
tous le compte quelque 1 on est tous
l'étranger de quelqu'un
bon bref on sait bien que ça marche vous
dit chez nous pas aller bien quand
j'étais petit palais bien c'était
inconcevable seul remède contre le
cafard c'était de faire le tour du pâté
de maisons c'était marche ou crève
et là vers l'âge de 5 6 ans vous
découvrez que finalement le rire peut
sauver les pires moments
et quand vous êtes à l'arrière de la
voiture d'origine que chez vous on a les
trois au milieu
moi je leur dis vous alliez faire des
tours en voiture j'imagine sa balade on
allait dans l'amont brison la ola le
village un peu plus petit que cet ancien
et voir les amis des jeunes est elle est
là vous découvrez en fait que dans la
voiture ou dit des vannes ça fait marrer
tout le monde donc vous dites je me
sentais responsable de leur bonheur à
tous oui c'est exactement ça responsable
j'avais cette responsabilité-là est
alors à l'époque un peu comme dans
marilyn la marilyn évidemment les coûts
de joe dassin en se mettant sa veste
blanche et sa chemise blanche vous vous
enfermez dans votre champ avec al
jarreau barry white et stevie wonder
c'est vrai que je crois que je me suis
chouchoutée ouais parce que deux
12 ans à 17 ans qu'on le déjeuner était
dure à peu près un quart d'heure c'est
papa plaisir donc on mange pour manger
quoi nous ça dure dix minutes à tout
casser un quart d'heure et après donc
jusqu'à jusqu'à la sonnerie de l'école
que j'entendais chez moi c'est vrai je
mettais tout c'est voilà tout ça j'étais
j'arrivais en classe j'étais saoul et
c'est une drogue sous la halle avec le
sentait rêver ça pour ce pauvre tenir le
coup il y avait ça ils veulent rire
évidemment il ya paris dire que d'un
seul coup comme beaucoup d'entre nous
vous dites je vais monter à paris parce
que là où toute façon tout est possible
donc vous arrivez ici est la première
chose que vous faites en arrivant on en
voit bien là la fille de marchand de
chaussures qu'elle avait marre de porter
les pompes qu'on lui faisait m vous
acheter des bottes magnifique c'est
marrant je sais exactement les votes
qu'on fait maintenant le fait grise très
pointu sabine un truc votre nom et de
tester les talons comme ça non mais
c'était plus basse à ses plus grands
chefs saint-etienne avait pas les
modèles comme ça des talons de 10
centimètres pour le tue donc j'étais
vous très embêté d'aller pour la
première fois dans un et je me souviens
j'ai laissé un pourboire l'a fait parce
que vend des chaussures c'est pas vendre
les endroits difficiles les chaussures
qui vont acheter des chaussures ils sont
insupportables et jean soir fait mal aux
pieds les aime pas la couleur elles sont
trop longues à sa part admis à niveau
etc
jusqu'à ce carton ça tombe si gênante
mais quand même j'ai l'impression de
tromper mes parents alors à paris vous
arrivez de cours florent pour préparer
le conservatoire et vous êtes reçu
première à l'entrée du conservatoire et
la faisait michel bouquet comme prof
c'est pas mal hein c'est mieux que ça
avait de la chance
et là vous travaillez l'aiglon agrippine
ce qui fait que finalement quand on
quand on vous voit dans marilyn les gens
ont l'impression que c'est comme ça le
truc qui vous a pris un jour
j'arrête de faire de la scène je vais
faire du cinéma vous avez commencé comme
ça
alors est ce que finalement le comique
ça a été une parenthèse mais c'est
incroyable cette histoire vous êtes
parti là non on va voir comment j'ai
jamais pensé moi j'aimerais a dit tiens
je vais partir de cet été pour faire ça
c'est pas c'est pas et je me suis
retrouvé quand il va faire ça on
m'aurait dit ça va durer 12 ans j'aurais
dit mais comment
mais alors qu'est ce que je devais faire
donc je vais rater plein de trucs donc
j'étais dans la dans le voyage et comme
voilà dans ces familles
ils ont commencé quand on a commencé
c'est vrai si on crée c'est impossible
de faire autrement
et alors là il ya un truc que difficile
à comprendre pourquoi c'est un coup de
blues à la fin du conservatoire pourquoi
vous rentrez pas dans une troupe de
théâtre
vous partez à saint-etienne revendre des
chaussures ça s'est un peu voilà c'est
d'être dur le jour vous êtes reparti non
c'est de rester et l'amener en amérique
centrale
mais comment tout seul non je m'arrête à
un ami quand je débouche avec un sac à
dos et voilà et on part pour deux mois
et je me dis ben voilà et quand je
reviens je vois là ça la vie c'est ça
ton qui va travailler un peu faire tu
t'en fous et tous les ans qui partira
deux mois c'est à dire deux mois on ne
regarde plus la date on y vend rentrer
dans une chaise à longwy le temps est
complètement
c'était en 80 je n'y ai plus jamais
c'est ça c'est vrai que chaque fois
j'avais un combat sous les pas de jean
giraudoux c'est ça ouais on est toujours
là lui c'est ça qu'on veut c'est pas
mieux et là on retourne reprenez à tout
à zéro avec roger louret les baladins de
l'agenais bouvard le petit théâtre mais
rencontre énorme avec pierre palmade
évidemment rien on a vu ce que ça a
donné bedos et puis là voilà vous fait
une carrière que complètement rien à
voir avec ce qui aurait dû être la vôtre
parce qu'au départ vote première
vocation c'est la musique et après vous
auriez dû faire du théâtre là vous
faites du one man show incroyable tout
seul sur scène mais vous dites au fond
je me sens comedians et cette phrase qui
très gentil je me sens plus proches de
suzanne flon que patrick bosso je fais
sont plus proches de suzanne flon
peut-être période voulait faire des
vacances à l'euro manoeuvre qui a
beaucoup cité
[Musique]
les lycées j'espère que vous le savez
mal robin on ne bouge pas j'ai même
répété à la maison ah bon ça si on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle maintenant
le génial
c'est mardi view
[Applaudissements]
la rébellion bien ficelé mater laissez
moi faire les efforts
si à la fin il ne fait pas le gage qui
sera écrit la sereine couilles molles
hockey muriel vous pensez à quoi la cha
ouais vous pensez à quoi
à rien souvent je pense à rien moi allez
ça va être agréable très très bouddhiste
100h croît naturellement du fait parfois
très bon comme vous étiez petit vous lui
ressemblez à qui je voulais être jésus
non tu as chanté que j'étais sage sap on
m'avait envoyé pour sauver le monde
après ils sont restés un peu trop de
boulot donc donc de jésus j'ai dû passer
annie girardot si oui alors je voulais
être là il a miné les [ __ ] tout ça oui
je vais pas me traiter à part ça qu'est
ce qui vous énerve le plus chez vous en
vous non c'est mais énervement je crois
que ça va mieux beaucoup mieux qu'est ce
qui vous énerve le plus chez moi
non peut-être parfois quand vous souriez
j'ai parlé tout le temps les yeux avec
je me dis sourit vraiment et sourit pas
c'est quand j'ai pas là quand ça marche
les lieux j'adore
et ce défi des marchés d'afrique secteur
que d'autres pensent qu'il est méchant
ouais qu'est ce qui vous a fait le plus
mal comme insulte réponse à l'offre sa
j'adore
non c'est quand on me dit mais chante on
l'a dit pas souvent on me l'a écrit une
fois ça j'aime pas non méchante mais où
se cache du monde du mariage avec le
noir il ya quelqu'un qui m'a écrit qui a
pensé qui m'a insulté m'a dit que
c'était très méchant de sketches et de
prendre de l'argent faisait de l'argent
sur le dos des noirs bon quand on vous
demande d'autographe vous écrivez quoi
alors ça alors c'est très bizarre parce
que bizarrement j'ai écrit mes robes à
fêter ça il ya pas une gradation mettait
pas amitié quand ceux ci demandent l'ajc
enfants je m'adresse bise parce que j'ai
peur c'est qu'est ce que vous feriez
s'il vous restait 24 heures à vivre 24
heures à 606 et en gelant les 24 heures
du mans 24 heures moi je pense à rien je
ferais rien 6 pts et j'irai chez ikea je
montrais un meuble ton monte
24 heures c'est un sûr quand est ce que
vous avez toujours et pour la dernière
fois hier
pour quelle raison parce que parce que
le saviez vous venez ici aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle fume sortait sa a fait à
une sorte de décompression voilà flash
et la bbc terrail fatigue dernière
personne que vous ayez eu envie de tuer
j'ai pas envie de tuer s'est pas montrée
même pas quand même de temps en temps
vraiment je vais à la poste ou à la sécu
n'ont pas menacé m voilà me tuer oui à
cause de la fille de la passe c'est vous
que c'est trop difficile
moi je voulais quitter le monde où il ya
la finale c'était à refaire votre vie
vous feriez quoi pas pareil je ferai de
la musique ça c'est sûr ah oui c'est à
ce point là et jouer du piano quand même
avoué ne rien faire un bon annoncerait
avec la musique que ça vraiment y'a pas
la guitare batterie vous devriez le
faire
j'ai déjà pensé au suicide oui oui alors
notre twitter pour les autres pour la
gym intéresse oui pourquoi j'avais très
bien être aussi fluide ou âmes un peu je
te laisse des trois lames de rasoir
tu regardes petit cancer mais vraiment
est-ce que vous organiserez un dîner où
on parle pas de vous oui si je ne suis
pas
[Applaudissements]
ban
dans un psy
maryline de mehdi karim j'accueille
maintenant muriel robin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
et oui muriel c'est un triomphe en bas
sinon from a en même temps le truand
fromage sachant que simple quand on a
quand on commence à avoir laissé
l'enfant que j'aurais plaisir quand même
très mais vous savez pourquoi
non parce que bon yaya il ya la pièce de
mimie mathy vous êtes auteur avec pierre
palmade
ils se sont aimés qu'il joue tous les
soirs avec michèle laroque au théâtre de
la porte saint martin est un énorme
succès
c'est ce qui fait en ce moment palmade
m
flash je te l'avais
[Musique]
c'est saint pierre n'a changé dans
l'écriture mais rien scénique avec les
séparent café la parole c'est pas que
des mots bleus donc j'ai dit mimi mathy
la pièce donc ils se sont aimés palmade
laroque
vous êtes toujours très impliqué dans
les restos du coeur il ya eu les trois
concerts à à marseille vous êtes
marraine de l'association des enfants
afghans
nous recevrons tout à l'heure nilan
moubarak qui nous parlera de son action
et de la vôtre par la même occasion
voilà quoi donc c'est ça mérite un
triomphe romain
si c'est ça c'est mieux que je peux
faire autre chose on va en parler après
alors on a déjà parlé de votre famille
la dernière fois vous êtes venu il ya
deux ans on avait fait le magasin de
chaussures les bords de champs elysées
en arrivant fait donc aujourd'hui on va
parler un peu du nôtre famille c'est
comment on fait
alors cet autre famille
muriel robin c'est celle qui vous
entourent dans la griffe la pièce que
vous interprétez à partir du 29 janvier
au théâtre fontaine avec berlin vers
l'est c'est une pièce qui est écrite par
claude d'anna et laure bonnet et mise en
scène par annie non ça me fait drôle de
voir à plusieurs
ouais on dirait que ça a été écrit pour
vous ça vraiment été fait pour vous non
pas du tout du tout du tout vraiment
c'était entre les madame x blancheteau
qui a pensé à moi pour le rôle
c'est vrai qu'elle n'est pas l'opposé de
moi parce que je crois qu'on a la même
carrure énergie peut-être force ya de la
force c'est mon âme mais après non je ne
suis pas allée j'aurais pas si j'étais
elle un peu plus je crois mais déjà
longtemps 10 15 ans et c'est ce qui fait
que je peux retrouver ce mail a joué
assez les choses sont des choses à
retrouver sinon je l'aurais mal joué je
pense où ça m'aurait dérangé j'aurais
pas su même ce que je jouais là je vais
me balader dans des endroits qui sont
plus qu'ils sont fermés chez moi c'est
une pièce qui était monté très
rapidement donc oui c'était bien aussi
parce que sinon moi je crois pas j'ai lu
ça m'a fait un peu j'avais eu la même
sensation avec le film marilyn
heureusement je suis allé au bout d'un
voyage seul d'un voyage de ce voyage de
dix ans avec un bonheur commande pas
quand on a la chance seul devant 4000
personnes chez les hommes on est entre
le rock n roll on sait même plus c'est
du théâtre jusqu en même temps on
travaille ça comme du shakespeare
c'est un truc magnifique ça mais bon une
phrase un rire c'était une pression que
je m'étais mise le temps passe moi j'ai
plus il ya dix ans de plus aussi donc
j'essaye je vais aller vers j'ai évolué
que mes personnages ne peuvent pas être
les mêmes
et puis faire des choses seulement parce
que ça marche ne me paraît pas une bonne
raison
ça peut durer ou pas ou vous revenir
dans la figure donc donc là c'est en
tout cas c'est parfaitement
effectivement exacte avec ce que ce que
j'ai envie de faire c'est ce que
j'aimerais c'est pouvoir aller là dans
l'émotion garder le rire élargir
l'éventail voilà parce que je peux pas
une phrase un reer j'adore ne pas couper
tous le temps pas toute la vie parce que
je vais mourir
et puis quand même pour autre chose que
parce que je peux rire ça va être un
gros carton la pièce je suis sûr qu'on
s'ennuie pas dans cette ville ça j'en
suis sûr la pièce est forte nous faut on
s'identifie à la mer un moment à la
fille à la soeur a moins on connaît ça
et puis ça renvoie à notre propre
famille on est enfermé avec eux dans ses
stations-service et on peut pas ne pas
dire en sortant tient et moi où j'en
suis et que ma mère ce que ça traite de
ça aussi qui est quand même il ya
dossier sur les maires quand même et on
a tous un peu
je sais que j'ai vu début de l'émission
c'est un peu compliqué c'est différent
moi je sais pas quoi dire dans ces cas
là parce que la pudeur même temps que la
fête continue
le pire est à venir
j'ai très peur quand vous avez réservé
ouais j'ai pas la voirie la raison leurs
vins interview alain delon
[Musique]
légaliser les drogues douces l'oubli des
stupéfiantes où elle trouve stupéfiant
que cela n'ait pas encore été fait
mairieen de longs voyages de l'ong pense
que c'est stupéfiant d'être stupéfait
c'est la conception du luxe c'est comme
un plombier jeudi l'île où et comment
elle va se battre à wes havas ouais mais
là je peux pas vous le savez ça va je
n'ai pas voulu mettre cette somme à
nantes pour faire du social
elle augmenterait les salaires ou elle
réduit le temps de travail
alors on est alors en basse saison mais
ses traits du jeune homme va alors
muriel robin qu'est-ce qu'elle emporte
le temps de travail et du social la très
chaud ce qu'elle dit alors pour taper la
femmelle préféré rouler sans bornes en
ferrari avec un boudin ou du bord en
tracteur avec un top canon muriel robin
préféré rouler dans une ferrari avec un
top canon des mélanges à l'ailé mais je
veux pas vendu l'autre ça ne va pas du
tout en tant que star ce qu'elle
supporte le moins six est l'objet de
toutes les conversations ou être l'objet
d'aucune barbade
supporte pas de ne pas être un sujet de
conversation et c'est ok évidemment je
sais pas je peux même pas l'imaginer
ouais elle commence à bien comprendre uc
ouais ça peut longtemps s'il va jouer
déjà d'arrêter près des télécoms ça donc
je pose alors évidemment que c'est plus
lent qu'à tel le sentiment d'avoir le
plus souvent raté sa chance d'être un ou
d occasion de la fermer
je crois que comme muriel lou romain
louvre ça c'est toujours pour quelque
chose venir rebelles ne rate jamais
traque lampe est d'accord et la foule
après ce qu'il faut aussi le faire parce
que la partie est monté sur le très bon
après faut calmer le jeu prend pas ce
commerce du sexe est ce qu'elle est pour
la réouverture des maisons closes ou
pour la fermeture des boîtes à partir
non normandin pense que les boîte à
partouze très agréable à vivre ici c'est
très drôles j'adore dire des mots que je
dis pas souvent pas pu fêter sa sortie
non pense que la femme n'ont que les
boîte à partouze je me souviens déjà vu
la question porte qu'il faut en tout cas
la leçon ouvertes et les maisons closes
aussi d'accord faut tout ouvrir mais
alors ma pense qu'il faut ouvrir vers le
bas et elle même très ouvert jacques
ne reviendra pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir montréal 100-120 ces trucs ces
bracelets c'est samuel benchetrit qui me
l'a offert pourquoi ça veut dire quoi
t'avais qu'à être là j'ai vu un peu en
contrebas bien non qu'est ce qu'en
pensent leurs gammes c'est bien mais
bien ça casse un peu le look très chic
ou que je peux avoir pendant la
grossesse
ouais ça amène des titres ça fait
rebelles bonsoir et bk alors si lé ton
actualité rebecca ces familles prononcé
cette sanction deux mamies alors muriel
robin vous avez déclaré au quotidien
belge la dernière heure le 7 décembre
2005 la télévision je déteste la preuve
j'en ai même pas chez moi
les plateaux je me rends uniquement
parce qu'il le faut pour la promotion à
la télé il faut faire rire immédiatement
en se mettant au service d'un animateur
nécessairement drôles ou talentueux
conclusion je n'aime pas ce que du
touriste vous qu'est ce que c'est mal
tourné parce que c'est beaucoup c'est
bon c'est plus doux que ça je vous aviez
dit et plus doux que ça c'est pas faux
vous avez raison si sûr non je n'aime
pas la télé je crois que parce que j'ai
pas parce qu'on peut pas avoir du talent
partout et qu'il faut la voir là aussi
que le texte n'est pas préparé et que
voilà il faut avoir du talent aussi
parce que quand vous passez beaucoup de
gens que vous regarde et que voilà et
qu'à la sortie on peut vous dire que je
trouvais bien ou pas bien tu as dix la
pâte
donc on est encore au front et c'est
moins facile je veux dire merial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en 2010 les écarts et noyal en avoir
fini avec le one woman show avec les
sketches pour vous consacrer au théâtre
et au cinéma
vous allez changer d'avis vous êtes
revenu avec un spectacle sans sketch
c'est peut-être le cinéma qu'à changer
de vivre un spectacle sans ce qu'être
j'en sais pas si tu dit j'arrête les
sketches et j'ai raté les sketchs jeudi
je fais je sais que j'arrêtais les
sketchs voilà votre spectacle ou le
secours coécrit avec pierre palmade
c'est pas une succession de sketches ces
deux heures dans la vie d'une femme qui
a eu l'idée de monter blanche neige et
les sept nains en comédie musicale
on est à 15 jours de la première autour
d'elle tout s'agite et en suisse le
personnage comme ça lisa qui parle à 19
personnes qui sont pas là c'est assez
pratique parce que vous avez une voix me
dit je me cogne pas une comédienne qui
jouerait estelle et qui mettrait six
secondes à sortir avec eux c'est
formidable ça a très vite personnel
ailleurs dix secondes elle est sortie
pour le rythme parce que c'est très
important ça compte beaucoup pour moi
c'est un rythme
voilà il ya du bon les personnages et tu
attendais les répliques avec guy bedos
s'attendait à des commissions tu
revenais 19 19 personnages imaginés 19
s'ils étaient tous là qu'on s'emmerde
bref voilà onze ans à peine se vendent
alors vous jouez vous chantez vous
dansez vous avez si boys autour de vous
et c'est trés procédure en faire ce que
vous faites là
ce qui est dur c'est de rester 1h50 avec
eu des mots avec 4000 personnes faire
que le temps s'arrête
être drôle avec des choses qui ne le
sont pas et être son propre héros aixois
entendant une barre à chaque force 10
ans ex à l'air d'être facile c'est cette
difficulté qu'il ne voit qu on ne voit
pas qui rend c'est de se mettre c'est
beau mais qui fait que c'est que ça
reste à faire tous les soirs et c'est
aussi difficile tous les soirs c'est
difficile à chaque fois oui de faire
partout tout le temps là on a voulu de
les tenir de ne pas les perdre d'être là
au millimètre celle du fils oui j'aurai
accès difficile mais parce que j'ai
choisi que ce soit difficile un risque
sinon je m'ennuierais vous avez quatre
cinq mille personnes tous les soirs au
total 300 mille spectateurs c'était fin
j'en est à 424 me
mais km 400 même pour te combien de
personnes par kilomètre et alors le dvd
lui il est pré vendu à 300 mille
exemplaires ce que vous allez faire
millions 2,1 millions de dvd quoi je
sais pas si ça existe ça réussisse igad
et jamel il faut un million millions dvd
à 20 euros le dvd muriel redonne à
l'afrique aussi aux balles normales ou à
l'asie où l asie c'est énorme
alors on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
je vais regarder votre caméra new york
c'est le cas le rouge
oui et vous allez dire magnéto serge
magnéto c'est là quand même une vie
privée assez compliqué sa mère est
atteinte de la maladie d'alzheimer sa
fiancé s'appelle nadine alors concernant
votre mère c'est autobiographique
pendant qu'elle était malade vous êtes
parti pendant un an à son chevet dans
l'appartement de votre enfance et à
saint-etienne est pas possible de vous
deux vous décollez dalle qua non non
parce que quand on sent quand on sait
pas d'ailleurs cette maladie on ne sait
pas que ça va faire mourir donc ce n'est
pas son reste parce qu'on sent que mais
cette maladie en tout cas je fais que
l'eia lâcher prise de la part des gens
qui l'ont et ma mère qui était plutôt
quelqu'un de dur enfin de voilà qui
était un tueur la dureté avait lâché
donc elle était menthe et et c'est sous
ce qu'on a envie de le prendre
et puis et puis
charnière quoi une phrase terrible et on
perd la personne mais elle est encore
vivant oui c'est terrible c'est terrible
c'est les mots pour expliquer ça parce
que c'est vrai qu'on devrait les plus là
on leur ferait un deuil et là on se dit
tous les matins on serait rien me suis
dit je vais faire comme cela dit je vais
faire un petit retour arrière et puis ça
va marcher parce que parce que parfois
ça marche donc taquet bien pourquoi ça
marche mais parfois ça marche comme ça
et celle des éclairs de lucidité puis à
un moment il y en a plus du tout il y en
a plus du tout quand l'avion le jour où
ma mère maggie q ces web muriel ouais
j'ai vécu une chose que j'ai entendu
cette expression le sang qui se glace
j'avais jamais connu ça ici j'ai eu le
sang qui s'est glacé
c'est un truc bon voilà donc qui après
il ya plus jamais ça connect plus et à
personne n'est plus là et plus alors
voilà le plus là alors à l'issue de
cette aventure tragique vous avez connu
une dépression assez grave
oui oui j'étais très mal quoi j'avais un
peu un moment jeter les yeux au plafond
et je m'en sortirais pas quoi oui même à
mag ressort à 10 faut l'admettre d'une
clinique psychiatrique faut pas laisser
comme ça je ça marchait plus
j'étais plus donc on a misé au bon
endroit dans un village d'ailleurs
j'avais fait ma terminale donc souvenirs
souvenirs peu importe et puis basse et
voilà il des gens dont c'est le métier
les psys tout simplement des choses
bêtes comme vous forcer à prendre une
douche en disant c'est avec de l'eau
chaude parce que ça active le sens et ça
voilà des gens des mots mais surtout ça
et après avoir bu un mois et demi deux
cliniques psychiatriques
gg j'étais debout voilà on vous a
proposé d'écrire un livre à ce moment là
oui après peu après j'ai commencé à
mettre des mots sur ça je les ai mis
d'ailleurs et et je dirais que ce qui
est intéressant dans cette écriture
parce que la bonne écriture peut-être
s'ils voient quelque chose à dire
d'intéressant c'est quand y en a plus du
tout censure l'autocensure
tant qu'il ya quelque chose qui sorte
avait comme ça donc j'ai pu balancer 40
pages qui sont je crois qu'à un moment
c'est ni bien ni pas bien quand c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est comme si
le c'est comme si on regarde le coeur et
comment y êtes dedans et puis ça m'a
fait aller mieux aussi ça et un moment
c'est drôle parce que je devais aller
mieux et puis j'ai voulu écrire puis
commencer à regarder ce que j'écrivais
l'essentiel est là j'ai pu écrire ce que
je te disais non l'adjectif est allé
voir en fait ce bouquin si vous êtes
servi de thérapie parce que vous dites
la selle n'est pas du tout une thérapie
pour monter sur scène il faut aller bien
c'est la plus magnifique des pommades
parce que pommade carton abobo ça fait
ça fait douze quoi ça fait du bien mais
ça ne guérit pas ça ne soigne pas non
plus nos thérapies aussi c'est que vous
êtes délesté de 15 kilos quand même mon
nom face à ce trafic avec ce poids alors
après on va dire des chiffres qu'il faut
les gens se foutent peut-être mais vous
êtes monté très haut là vous êtes monté
à 94 quand même mais c'est fait j'ai pu
un moment je me suis kg de la centaine
mais je me suis dis pas ce que je fait
j'avais beaucoup
oui j'avais déjà faisait pas rire tous
mes amis d'ailleurs je pense est neutre
ans mon attachée de presse louis duzert
préval
on va faire une belle fête parce que à
la fin d'année on a fait tilt quintal et
ça la faisait pas rire les gens que
j'aime j'aime beaucoup ça d'aisé paris
c'est pas moi c'est culot moi j'étais
super bien gaulée j'ai fait 60 kg
jusqu'à 35 ans j'avais un accord nickel
et puis c'est qu'ils ne sont pas moins
ils représentent ce qui n'est pas à moi
dedans quand j'enlève gens l'aiment
j'enlève ils vont partir avec
quand vous parlez de vous à l'époque ya
quelques années sur scène vous du jt
engoncés dans des vêtements trop serrés
je vais la tête qui dépassait avec la
coupe la plus courte possible
l espèce de machine de guerre quoi
qu'est-ce que c'est ce visage carré ses
cheveux courts cette fille qui a comme
ça qui est finie jolies pages avis
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc à
lambiel un boulot à faire quand je vois
les images aujourd'hui je me dis que
j'ai un peu beau c'est mieux ça va très
bien retenir ces moyens là on vous a
connu plus alors vous êtes vous êtes
délester aussi de beaucoup de choses
vous aviez des pièces remplies de cd
ampli gleave rempli de fringues
brest 10 objets mais les objets les dix
objets que j'ai chez moi je n'étais pas
très bibelots mais quand même les
disques des jeux c'est pourquoi ils sont
là ils ont un sens donc c'est pas mal et
l'appartement où il avait vendu il est
en libye en ce moment vous disiez tant
pis j'ai habité chez line renaud aussi
avec n'importe où ou moi aussi je me
suis dit ça dit non mais mal foutu à la
porte
il était autour de la pâte à saint
germain en sixième mais m² 150 mais
répondait répondait que c'était
important sur 550 m² méthanier c'est la
m
tous les décès très gentil pour la
démone vous dit puisque tu as dit me dit
vous êtes vous voulez vous que vous
étiez parfait tous les deux donc je ne
sais pas c'est sûrement mois voilà sa
coupe et donc sont carrément et tu le
vends combien suivant le prix que coûte
c'est à dire
2 millions d'euros 2 millions d'euros
donc quelqu'un d'intéressé séquelles rue
je suis sûr que les gens regardent bien
sûr des richert et 1,81 dans le sixième
jeu mais bon je touche se mettre à
plusieurs
après tout c'est un peu quand on est aux
normes et donc de millions mais tu che
négociable ou pas deux millions c'est ce
que ça coûte donc voilà deux millions de
terminer vous enlevez tout je m'en fous
c'est clair c'est 2009 où c'est très
bien c'est bon c'est sûr du tout je suis
dans cette maison mes charges pas trop
de charges et bénéfices de ta pièce tu
sais ce qu'il faut faire
y a pas qu'à attendre petite vingtaine
d'années machete la porte bien alors
dans au secours lisa l'héroïne
bisexuelle et challans est passé comme
une lettre à la poste sur les gens que
vous avez dit ça sur scène vous dites
mon fiancé s'appelle nadine cela pas
choquer les gens pas sauter en l'air
non alors moi je veux être
quant à un moment quand il fallait que
cette fille une fois qu'on ait fait
rentrer la mère c'est la seule fallait
bien qu'elle ait une vie privée est la
plus pire n'était plus avec moi jusqu'au
moment il n'a plus pu écrire avec ma
lampe j'étais seul je me suis dit bon
évidemment l'état est un mec et j'étais
avec roger louret mon metteur en scène
et je lui dis c'était qu'une femme est
ce que c'est pas plus drôle plus drôle
surtout ceux dans la fiction après
savoir si lisa c'est comme moi on peut
se poser la question
vous posez la question moi je vous la
poserai pas parce que comme il s'agit
d'une discrétion légendaire je vois que
tout le monde le sait dans ce pays sort
mais oui dans des bars certaines
émissions et d'une pudeur ne vous dis
pas mais la police ne l'imposé pas et
j'apprécie parce que ça fait plusieurs
fois que je viens
c'est plusieurs mois si on était à la
fête les gens sont mal à l'aise mais
puisque vous me la poser pas je vous
réponds c'est que je prends l'amour là
où il est l'allié très courte
il nage il que pour vous les crimes à
l'être humain est plus important que le
sexe diamants
quoi ma part ceci étant je vais déclarer
je sait depuis toujours que je finirais
ma vie avec un homme
oui j'ai dit sage et bien c'est pas bien
parce que c'est déjà encore me foutent
rien je sais rien je sais rien je suis
je sais rien je sais rien je sais rien
mais donc au secours est un gros succès
le dvd va cartonner et pourtant
récemment on vous a beaucoup entendu
vous vous plaindre dans les médias de ce
que personne vous propose deux films au
cinéma
vous dites on ne désire pas pourquoi
qu'est-ce que j'ai qui leur déplaît à
mayol voilà ce que je suis trop blonde
est ce que je suis trop grosse excuse et
le menton trop trop carré parce que
quand on est populaire c'est une
constatation est un bonheur mais depuis
maintenant plus de quinze ans l'une des
plus populaires peut-être voilà je suis
dans la vérité et c'est vrai je n'ai pas
de proposition mais pas un point qui
fait qu'au début on dit bon ben c'est
pas grave
et puis d'ailleurs mais au début puis
après aussi on dit c'est pas grave on
dit plus on aide parce qu'on a de
l'orgueil donc on dit ça tombe bien
puisque toute façon moi non plus je veux
pas deux camps ont fini par se trouver
voilà et puis et puis on peut aussi un
moment s'est arrêtée puis se dire si
j'enlève l'orgueil moi je me suis dit si
tu enlèves lhenry américaine qu'est ce
que ça fait et j'ai pleuré mais vraiment
ce que je me suis dit à ce point là rien
à me proposer pourquoi depuis le dante a
pas écrit est un truc
d'autres si vous désirez et je vais déjà
me mettre des gens à doucy je veux en
faire un vix parfois ce que je peux voir
je pense que je peux en écrire un par
mois deux pas de ses problèmes de faire
un film c'est le désir d autres façons
de les gens ne savent pas mais peut-être
que j'aurais dû plus le dire mais j'ai
fait le conservatoire je pense que je
vais avoir un parcours comédienne puis
se trouve que j'avais appris avec michel
bouquet oui enfin je vois je moi je sais
pas spécial du mois de match mais jamais
de ma vie je sais ça et je trouve que je
le fais plus que sa map façon c'était ça
ou rien
ça fait 15 ans et vous avez reçu que des
scénarios vous dites avec des rôles
pitoyable de camionneuse qui jure équipe
est enfin pas des trucs y revint
scénario à plein temps et un tri tu mets
donc encore une fois je suis dans la
vérité je dis que ça me fait de la peine
je dis clairement je dis que je veux
bien je dis encore d'autant plus je le
dire d'autant plus que le one man show
celui là était différent le prochain
c'est même pas sûr morin et c'est vrai
que si je suis désirer dans ce métier je
suis sûr que même mâchoire deviendront
un peu plus voilà un peu plus
triangulaire et que ce que je dirais
super en ce moment ça va bien et quand
d'irakiens cette fille elle et elle va
bien qu elle est sympa la carapace elle
vient pas de rien parce que ça dit quoi
d'être désiré c'est un moment une
famille mais je parle pas d'une famille
de cinq six personnes mais la famille de
ce métier voilà ce métier qui est j'ai
envie qu'ils me prennent dans leurs bras
à l'avancé bon jeu moi je n'ai fais ce
métier c'est qu'on l'ait vraiment
l'aimer motivation mais je me disais un
jour cela l'appui molière ont validé les
mois qui vont tous me regarde et puis je
vais leur dire merci vous être ma
famille puis je vous dis merci ce que
grâce à vous binger va aider à vivre
et puis ça arrive jamais n'arrive jamais
donc jeudi une famille parce que pas de
parents pas d'enfant famille dans le
non mais voyez ce que je veux donc bon
mais si ça doit être comme ça ça ira et
surtout très important mais vraiment
c'est pas une plainte
c'est juste que j'ai le droit de dire ça
aussi même si j'ai vécu c'est pendant
ces quinze ans beaucoup de beaucoup de
bobos si j'ai reçu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'amour et et comment que
j'aime ce public parce que il a été
tellement là et que ça m'a aidé a tonné
aussi seule vidéo vous avez eu débat on
va faire une interview à peine de ce que
vous préférez en vous ma compassion
naturellement un agent est tout le temps
est toujours quoique si vous ne
supportez pas en vous quand on oblige à
ne plus avoir compassion pour me
protéger parce que ça va trop loin
votre plus gros coup de fric à part la
partie non plus beaucoup de fric alors
celui là
j'aime bien aime bien parce que c'était
il ya un an 80
11 est une marque enfin c'est une marque
les petits c'est la charcuterie cérons
comme ça et purée ça s'appelle bâton de
vue d'accords et et m'a sollicité et
c'était un contrat en 91 moi ça faisait
pas longtemps que je commençais à est
proposée sur une campagne de trois ans 9
millions de francs et j'ai dit c'est
bien de réfléchir et ça m'a pris une
nuit j'ai vu tout ce que je pouvais je
te fait penser à ma famille à mes sa
femme bref à tout ça alors ça cela
c'était texto fait que c'est bien le
monde moderne c'est surtout que j'ai dit
je vais pas le faire parce qu'il n'ya
aucune somme d'argent qui justifiera
tout pendant 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans et des
gens une personne 10 personnes qui dans
la rue me disent c'est un bâton gager
secunia par l'argent d'un soldat et par
des blessures ma plus grosse perte
c'est ça aussi ça voilà d'accord le mot
que vous dites le plus facilement
merci le mot vous dites le moi
facilement sous le creps soumettrait je
ne dis pas ça c'est sûr ça me fait peur
ce qui me fait le plus rire dans la vie
mais rien les gens qui disent souvent
sur une nouvelle - ce qui me fait moins
rire c'est qu'on ne trouve pas une
réponse à une question
et puis dans d'autres villes aujourd'hui
il y en a eu beaucoup certainement mais
bien sûr mais je pense à qui arrivait et
voilà le dernier mardi c'était le jour
de la dernière régis lembeye le matin de
pierre palmade qui m'a dit qu'il allait
bien qu'il avait arrêté avec ses démons
tout ça en était sorti et qu'ils aient
besoin de me dire qu'il me mais c'est
bien vrai qu'il avait il m'a écrit comme
j'ai 2 bras jules muriel dans ma vie ce
thème là je l'attendais depuis 15 ans
parce que bagarre il va pas est-ce que
c'est comme ça et là la compassion
j'étais obligé de la chaire budge
serreau quand vous irez de lâcher ce que
ce ne serait pas possible c'était et ça
c'était un moment et je dis bien
évidemment j'ai si tu peux passer ce
soir il est arrivé à la fin du spectacle
il est monté sur scène non si c'était à
refaire
j'ai vu le père que j'aime l'homme en
revue mercredi
si tu le regardes bien merci pour tes
fleurs à ses très gentille et le plus
mauvais moment de votre vie
ouais ce qui vous détend le plus dans la
vie ce qui vous énerve le plus les
énervements votre plus belle histoire
d'amour
le public et non pas deux
[Applaudissements]
bah ouais mais bon comme je l'appelle et
je pensais des personnes qui ont
traversé ma vie c'est pas grave
entendent mettre comprenez bien que ça
c'est la mode voilà c'est comme ça
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on y met tous
c'est histoire d'amour et puis la vie
privée elle en prend des bons coups et
la plus minable histoire d'amour qui est
pas de minables de choses minables dans
ma vie thierry je vous remercie monsieur
l'endroit où vous rêveriez d'être en ce
moment souhaitiez précédent mondial est
en train de regarder ses missions
l'endroit vous détesteriez trans moment
on ne leur nuit d'amour qui nous empêche
de dormir un mot si compliqué c'est sûr
nécessitant levante avaient fait ce que
j'avais à vous dire c'est la boule l'a1
je suis comme tout grand vide à bhl
comme c'est génial quel est votre
meilleur souvenir de cuite gtx josiane
balasko et je n'étais pas bien je l'aï
moins vu qu'elle et moi toujours prêt
vous demande tu viens joseph chanter
j'ai dit c'est pas bien c'est dans un
coin chif
vous me n'a pas fini de lui dire tu es
payé je m'étais payer un ensemble un
truc noir de marque japonaise intrus
j'avais s'assimile balle que stark bas
j'étais aigles à gué bons mecs étaient
alors avec palmes à tout à l'heure
un jour j'ai posé la question j'ai dit
quel est votre pire souvenir de cuite
mais je me souviens pas jeter tout ce
que vous avez fait donc être la plus
fière c'est pas à montrer de pierre
c'est patrick jarry à sartre éclat mais
je pense que si c'était normal je
pourrais être fiers par exemple
de savoir que je ne suis pas pour rien
dans la construction d'un hôpital à
kaboul voilà mais je suis pas fier je
suis content bon c'est vrai que vous
n'avez pas vous n'avez pas d'enfants
mais vous occuper quand même des enfants
avaient grandi à pour vous je sais pas
qui c'est je vous dire non au numéro
privé est chaud oui oui qui dirait
pareil c'est un mec qui demande jamel
debbouze avait trois fois qu'ils
téléphonent il faut pas l'appeler sur
mon portable monsieur rappelé rappelle
dans un petit moment il est pas encore
là monsieur merci non il est pas encore
là dacca je les potes que jamais cet
hôpital c'est magnifique quoi ce que
voilà on a dit qu'on le ferait on l'a
fait trois ans et demi les 152 salariés
au moment où on se parle
ils sont couchés sur mais 150 voilà les
premiers fonds été opéré on appellerait
là-bas à lesterps on le permet poursuit
oxygène et c'est énorme et c'est vrai
que c'est pas fier mais quand je suis un
vrai les yeux je ne regretterai jamais
la voir comme ça de savoir qui appellera
maman et l'enfant qui est sauvé et que
j'allais dire que j'y suis pour quelque
chose je ne veux pas le dire qu'un
enfant qui est sauvé voilà peut être ce
avec deux loges pour le sort de leur
profession de loches eric cheysson et je
suis pour ça j'ai apporté ce que
l'hystérie avec alain deloche c'est des
mecs ça nous mène à la caméra sur nous
faire voilà alors l'un de leurs chevaux
la grille il a écrit un bouquin il parle
de son métier de sa trajectoire
on est en direct les commissions de pair
avec loïs à aussillon à ses racines avec
cinq ans c'est magnifique c'est que de
l'humanité que de l'amour que des belles
choses
donc je dis les semblants à la ddt de
loges
c'est du lourd
le héros vous préférez robin des bois le
héros que vous détestez les princes
charmants cédera voix qu'est-ce qu'on
paye cher tout non celui là je chapeaute
le plus grand acteur du monde pour vous
jamais un oui est le plus nul banier
tellement nul qui se recrutent je peux
dire son nom ne soit même pas que c'est
lui la plus grande actrice du monde
je crois que c'est moi et la crise la
venue du monde evan ans elle est mariée
avec la plus mûre et sa femme
puisqu'elle plus sexy en vo muriel
difficile c'est christian d'euros je
dirais peut-être là c'est dire est que
peut-être c'est mon ambiguïté peut-être
votre bouche tout petit et un peu je
m'étais jamais vraiment bien c'est bon
ma mère elle a brusquement ce qu'il ya
de moins sexy en vous merial peut-être
moins sexy c'est qu'on n'a pas que donne
pas cette ambiguïté je sais pas je m'en
bourg je sais pas c'est moins sexy
c'est pas que l'on va être plus direct
ce que vous préférez dans le sac alors
comme ça que j'aime beaucoup la partie
qui affame ou est-ce qui vous dégoûte
dans le set la partie qui avec 6
au secours le vvd dépendants
[Musique]